c'est vrai qu'on peut voir les arbres
qui sont encore brûlés par le gène à
l'arrivée dans son verger pour aurélien
soubeyrand le constat est sans appel
voilà donc là en avançant dans le
d'enlever relevé
on peut constater aussi que ce soit en
haut de la parcelle ou sur le bas les
fleurs sont entièrement grille et jusque
jusqu'au bas déranger voilà et ce sur
toute la surface de l'exploitation
on est à une semaine post gel on
constate que tous les pistes ils sont
grillés et quelques fleurs fleurissent
et on peut constater aussi que les
pistes il n'existe plus donc les
étamines sont présentes
on a un petit peu deux pétales mais tout
est complètement sec et grillé ceci ne
pourra plus de polliniser quoi sur 24
hectares de cultures de cerises 21 avant
deux hectares sont anéantis selon lui
une perte estimée à plus d'un demi
million d'euros difficile de tenir dans
ces conditions surtout après les années
médiocres qui l'a connu antérieurement
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui comme moi
l'an dernier j'ai perdu 45 j'ai pas
mangé fait 45% de récolte j'ai perdu 65%
de ma récolte pas avec nous elle je vais
avoir des indemnités cette année mais
qui ne compenseront jamais les perdre
même le système assurantiel ne permet
pas de compenser ces pertes les coûts de
cotisations à l'hectare sont très élevés
deux raisons à cela une faible surface
mutualiser et la répétition des
sinistres au point que certains
assureurs refusent de couvrir les pertes
liées aux aléas climatiques
c'est pourquoi la fédération nationale
des producteurs de fruits at on jase
gouvernementale fort sur le dispositif
de calamité agricole ou mousson qu'on
attend et ce qu'on demande c'est que
celui ci soit renforcée que les
indemnisations perçues par les
agriculteurs puissent être plus élevé
que ce qui est prévu aujourd'hui et
puisse être versée plus rapidement aussi
puisque certains certains arbaud n'ont
pas encore perçu les indemnités des
aléas
20 voire de fin 2019 dans le sud de
l'ardèche même constat lolita a repris
l'exploitation familiale depuis janvier
dernier l'épisode de gel a jeté un froid
sur ses espérances
je vous cache pas que j'ai préféré me
lancer une année extraordinaire et
exceptionnel
je n'arrive pas à estimer les pertes sur
une parcelle comme ça on voit que les
paires sont très importantes à plus de
80% sans problème al'inverse des abris
culteurs le système d'assurance sont
plus avantageux pour les viticulteurs
nous souscrivant une assurance récolte
qui est calculé sur nos volumes des cinq
dernières années et qui me permet
d'établir un volume moyen de récolter
sur lequel on peut construire un capital
quoi outre le plan global
d'indemnisation promis par le ministre
de la culture dont la somme sera connu
la semaine prochaine les producteurs
agricoles n'espère que deux choses
sauver ce qui peut l'être et attendre de
meilleures saisons